ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
aquí esto es la expresión y yo creo que
el arte la expresión del ser algo muy
importante para mí siempre ha sido el
poder ser esas personas que dejan que
crean que que llaman a la gente para
hacer algo diferente y tengo 10 años
trabajando cambio de ser el artista el
activista para convertirse en el artista
y de alguna manera parte de este
proyecto es el calcar lo que somos como
siempre se usó la cultura o el arte como
una bandera para poder
a mostrarle al mundo un cambio para
poder hacer con la gente algo que
querían hacer que querían mostrar
desde hace muchos años mucho mucho
tiempo desde que estaban las pinturas
rupestres siempre he dicho usan el arte
como un medio de comunicación como una
manera de poderle mostrar al mundo lo
que querían lo que veían lo que querían
cazar lo que querían comer y es lo que
seguimos haciendo los artistas somos
creadores de una forma
de una forma más sublime para poder
crear este tipo de proyectos y yo empecé
este que se madura la hermandad
exactamente hace dos años con ocho meses
y ha sido una idea tras otra tras otra
de poder crear por medio del arte una
ideología diferente sobre lo que si bien
es en nuestra frontera en este mundo el
mundo en que creemos que a lo mejor todo
es bonito o algunas piensan que es color
de rosa otras
bueno diferentes formas no pero vivimos
en un mundo lleno de colores y cada uno
lo ve de diferente forma el puede ser
artista y poder crear el activar a la
gente ideologías el crear proyectos para
que la política cambie también porque
realmente no nomás es él el artista
bohemio que se la pasa divirtiéndose o
tomando o bueno haciendo lo que algunos
de ustedes personas podrían decir quién
es el amigo el más locuaz el artista no
el músico el bailarín el pintor bueno
también aparte de eso tenemos la otra
parte seria que lo que queremos es crear
conciencia e inclusividad el crear una
forma o una potencia diferente para que
la humanidad crea en nosotros como un
medio de comunicación fuerte y lo ha
sido es muchos años
cuando digo ribera se metió a la
política cuando picasso hizo laverni acá
hablando sobre el tema que se vivía en
ese entonces y hasta la fecha los
artistas españoles y no usando
como una bandera para hablar sobre el
tema de inmigración sobre la gente eso
la conquista
y lo seguimos sigue nosotros aquí en la
frontera y para algunos otros o los que
vivimos en la frontera sabemos que aquí
en esta zona es el límite es el sueño
roto el último el de un paisaje bonito
que van a ver de américa bueno para
muchas muchas personas el tener un
concepto de es centroamérica llegar y
topar en tijuana y ver un muro
fronterizo las agota y les agota les les
llena de
no sé
es difícil ver a la gente que viene de
centro y sudamérica y que vean un piso y
que vean a la gente que está al otro
lado que no te permite pasar y ya no es
uno ahora son dos y en otras zonas a
tres muros
pero para una persona como yo y para
algunos colegas que ya la fecha van más
de 600 artistas que se han sumado este
proyecto
vemos el muro fronterizo como un lienzo
un lienzo para expresarnos un lienzo
para poder crear esa nostalgia en algo
diferente darle una vida a algo que te
puede llevar a la muerte y para mucha
gente el ver el muro fronterizo podría
algo
muy común siempre he dicho los que viven
en tijuana y nacen con visa no se han
preocupado por el muro fronterizo
los clientes juanan
y luego no ocupan la visa porque
decidieron irse al otro lado y tratar de
diversión americano tampoco les preocupó
el muro fronterizo
los que de plan están muy a gusto aquí
en la frontera y no necesitan ir eeuu -
les preocupa el muro fronterizo es
cierto entonces tratamos de ver la forma
la vida de diferente diferente manera y
una de ellas cuando empecé con el muro
fronterizo voy a empezar a pintar porque
es parte de del nervio y puede hacer
otra cosa y cómo es esto lo divertido de
mi vida no mucha gente dice que el
pintar te relaja
el pintar te lleva a otro nivel de
serenidad
por eso si una cosa cuando empecé a
pintar el muro fronterizo del primero de
diciembre de 2016
la idea era crear con la gente vincular
el arte con la sociedad y de alguna
manera ver cómo podíamos hacer que la
vida en la frontera fuera diferente
cubriendo el muro fronterizo
con un color azul cielo tratando
desvanecer lo para que no se se viera se
borrara
y parte de ese proyecto se fue haciendo
gracias a hasta la fecha casi 4.000
personas venido de todas partes del
mundo a pintar
la gente que conoce tijuana sabe que
esto lo vimos a diario la gente que
viene el centro de mexico de sudamérica
no sabe que los migrantes llegan y se
quedan aquí la mayoría con un sueño roto
con una forma
diferente de vivir
pero algo que me gustó cuando empecé el
proyecto es que entre las hierbas
entre los matorrales cerca de mosúl
utilizo habitaban por lo menos en un año
me encontré como unas 90 90 95 personas
que dormían entre las hierbas cerquita
del monte viso
las notas y las ve
pasan desapercibidas por ahí cuanto vas
pasando por la internacional
y algo
que me hacía
sentir diferente era de que yo no tuve
esa esa forma de estar ahí al me tocó
llegar pararme con un sueño decir vamos
a cambiar muy fronterizo por eso vamos a
hacer algo que que atraiga a la gente
pero yo sabía que los migrantes iban a
unir ahorita la fecha
y gracias de la caravana migrante que
vinieron a tijuana que estuvieron con
nosotros que son pintando trajeron los
sueños de mucha gente y los pintaron y
los grabaron sobre el muro si van hacia
playa se darán cuenta como empiezan a
hablar sobre sus historias sobre esa
tragedia de venir en la bestia sobre esa
tragedia de haber cruzado y regresado
pero la pintura como todo tema
los llevo a sentirse libres por un
momento y cuando hablas con ellos y les
preguntas qué sienten al estar pintando
el monterizo poniendo o escribiendo o
pintando un mensaje positivo das cuenta
que lo que ellos sienten es la fantasía
de un sueño la fantasía de querer lograr
ser a ser alguien o estar en un lugar
donde nunca y no saben ni cómo es la
experiencia de una persona como yo que
vivió en eeuu por más de 10 años que vio
sueño americano
qué estudio qué trabajo
que le dedicó la mitad de su vida a
pagar impuestos
porque es muy diferente para
imposibilidad que la cara como es ahora
decidí cambiar esa rutina y cuando lo
voy a los pregunto
este momento es vivir el sueño mexicano
de este lado también lo puedes vivir y
hay muchas frases dicen que de este lado
también hay sueños pero algunas de las
cosas que uno hace o realiza por medio
del arte es esto el influenciar el
cambiar la ideología de la gente el
cambiar el movimiento social activo
político religioso bueno miles de
movimientos que suceden en esta frontera
y eso lo estamos logrando por medio del
arte
que solo que la gente sigue acercando
como cuentan hace ratito varios de
varios de estos proyectos se fueron
dando junto con la gente que fue
viniendo el llegar a una frontera o el
ir a otro otro país y hablar sobre lo
que se vive en esta frontera es lo que
ha llevado a que nosotros los artistas
cree creamos y pensemos que esto sí
puede ser una herramienta perfecta para
cambiar el mundo tratamos de hacerlo de
una forma diferente queremos ver la
manera de de ser abstractos de ser
surrealistas
de ser
diferente solamente
cuando empezamos a pintar
esta eran eran láminas eran unas plazas
de láminas que trajeron de la guerra del
golfo y las pusieron sobre sobre tijuana
todas de estas playas todo que venía
hacia el centro bajaba a tecate mexicali
eran láminas y láminas traídas de una
reserva de ella
ahora hace ocho meses decidieron cambiar
un puro por seis metros esa misma pieza
tiene el mismo simbolismo para eeuu como
para la gente de otras partes del mundo
pero no para méxico las personas que
creemos
pintamos con las positivas
pintamos
lo que no queremos ver
hablamos de cosas que la gente a veces
no entiende
pero busca si usa diario de reunidos al
cartel el muro fronterizo para arte en
frente de él hablar con la gente que
habita allí y empezar a pintar algo
positivo porque no se siente algo
positivo
y eso es lo que pasa con el arte no
sabes dónde lo vas a plasmar
simplemente lo haces porque lo sientes
el arte activa el arte promueve el arte
te hace sentir diferente pero cuando lo
sabes manejar cuando es una forma
e inclusiva cuando es una forma con
causa cuando es una forma en la que tú
creas un concepto diferente porque no es
fácil crear un proyecto todo ha sido
inventado ya todo ha sido creado alguna
manera luego tiende a ser un concepto
diferente
parte de este proyecto llevó a gente a
unirse les comentaba que la idea de
juntar más de 4000 personas no fue fue
sin querer se me salió de las manos a
este proyecto está apuntado en nuestro
rocosa toshiba de arte urbano japonés se
unió el maestro francisco toledo de
oaxaca falleció hace poco se unido
rolling listón de los sabios urbanos más
grandes que hay en estados unidos se han
unido 600 artistas con la idea de poder
cambiar de poder usar un lienzo de poder
crear un proyecto como algo más humano
pero en una zona donde humanitariamente
no es
muy bonito
tenemos la
la idea de seguir pintando el muro
sabrán que son 3000 kilómetros lineales
de muro fronterizo de aquí hasta reinosa
a la fecha llevamos
2 km en tijuana médico intra tecate se
logró pintar medio en mexicali
y aún a partir de la quitaron
acabo de regresar de reynosa río bravo y
se pintó una parte en frente del muro
ah
el primera pinta de los dos lados del
muro fronterizo
era aprovechar todo el lienzo que
podríamos pudiéramos usar para crear un
concepto binacional un movimiento que
fuera sostenido por la gente
activando
el lienzo más grande en el mundo
que tenemos
para poder crear un concepto diferente
con la gente
no están no es tan bonito como cómo se
siente cuando usas el arte como una
forma de
de protestar porque aunque es algo
pacífico la gente sigue tomando este
tema como algo amarillista entonces
suele pasar que la gente te considere
como una persona que se aprovecha de la
sociedad y la verdad es que no es eso
todos los artistas tenemos una forma
diferente de pensar de crear y yo
aproveche el insumo más grande que
tenemos es una de las formas
de poder mostrar a la humanidad que
cualquier cosa por más fea una ideología
más tonta de alguna persona de crear un
concepto anti humano lo podemos
convertir en algo bonito en algo
interactivo en algo colectivo
y eso es lo que es ahora y me da
muchísimo gusto que ahora la gente desde
que se para ahí a ver el muro fronterizo
ahora se para a ver el mural de la
hermandad y eso es lo que estoy haciendo
yo así que
espero pronto verlos por allí muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]